c'est toujours l'été il fait chaud et
beau et le soleil invite encore aux
apéros à rallonge et c'est aussi le
moment d'aller batifoler dans les champs
tiède et moite
mais vous n'êtes pas les seuls à aimer
vous roulez dans les airs de ôte l'épée
c'est la fête y compris pour les vcs
qu'elles sont vraiment dangereux
comment les éviter que faire si on est
piqué la réponse à toutes ces questions
avec des thés ses partenaires de votre
épée avoir des passions communes
ça rapproche alors autant vous le dire
tout de suite après une grande balade en
forêt ou dans les herbes folles vous
pourriez bien ramener avec vous des
nouvelles amies l'éthique
à quoi ça ressemble une éthique et bien
c'est très simple une tique c'est ni
plus ni moins qu un acarien donc ça
ressemble à un acarien alors ok si vous
n'avez pas eu de contact visuel avec un
acarien récemment une tique ça ressemble
à ça ou à ça si ça vient de manger
oui parce que c'est un petit peu
compliqué de vous donner sa taille et
son poids précis vu que ça dépend pas
mal de 1 son stade de développement
2 si c'est un mâle ou une femelle 3 si
vous la croisez à l'apéro ou au moment
du digestif mais en gros si vous voulez
vous faire une idée
voilà ce que ça donne autant vous dire
que dans tous les cas c'est pas des
bêtes de course
le quoi le problème avec les tic le
problème avec les tic
ces packs épique juqu'à pique pas c'est
qu'elle mordent du guémon alors vous
allez me dire ou es europe ne doit pas
faire bien mal des toutes petites dents
comme ça alors déjà le truc avec lequel
elles mordent
ça s'appelle un rostre donc prenez pas
trop la confiance calmez-vous un petit
peu et laissez moi finir le vrai
problème avec l'éthique c'est que quand
elle nous piquent elles peuvent nous
refourguer des saloperies jean fièvre
hémorragique encéphalite et une autre un
petit peu plus connus les tic peuvent
être porteuse d'une bactérie appelée la
borrelia et donc refilé la borréliose
qui est plus connu sous le nom de
maladie
leim c'est une maladie qui se soigne
plutôt bien si elle est détectée est
prise en charge à temps mais dans le cas
contraire il peut y avoir des
complications neurologiques articulaires
ou toucher certains organes
est ce qu'on a envie de ça dans un autre
registre
aux états unis on a parlé d'une variété
particulière de tic appelé lone star
truc quand même pour trouver des noms
les américains nous on aura plus de
viande à là où je sais pas quoi la drôme
ce temps la plaque oui bon sceptiques
elle a la particularité de rendre
allergique à la viande
alors bon si vous comptiez devenir vg ça
peut être un petit coup de pouce mais
sincèrement je le conseille pas d'autres
moyens
vous avez compris dans tous les cas même
si toutes les tic sont pas porteuses de
saloperies susceptible de voir un malade
le mieux c'est quand même d'éviter de
fricoter avec comment on fait pour les
éviter
bah oui voilà c'est un peu ça le
problème inverse et se cachent dans les
airs dans les bois c'est tout petit
c'est là comme si c'était hyper facile
de les repérer le seul truc que vous
pouvez faire si vous prévoyez une grande
balade dans la nature c'est de vous
couvrir les bras et les jambes avec des
vêtements longs et les pieds avec des
chaussettes et des chaussures et la tête
et les inuit avec un chapeau vous pouvez
aussi mettre du répulsif mais renseignez
vous avant auprès de votre pharmacien
parce qu'il en a qui sont déconseillés
aux enfants ou aux femmes enceintes
et si c'est trop tard on fait quoi alors
évidemment on va voir ce qu'il faut
faire si on a été mordu par une tique
mais pour pouvoir mettre ses conseils en
application faut déjà être au courant
qu'on a été mordue oui parce que une
tique c'est pas un pitbull
quand elle meurt on s'en rend pas compte
donc la première chose à faire quand
vous revenez d'une grande balade dans la
nature c'est de vous inspecter la peau
pour voir s'il ya des tic accrocher
quelque part oui parce que une tique
c'est pas le genre qui mord et qui
s'enfuit en courant après oui 1 revient
pas avec la mer en octobre d'après elle
elle mord un reste en place et elle se
bat pour deux hot 100 donc vérifier qui
en a pas qui sont en train de profiter
du buffet à volonté dans un coin de
votre sympathique anatomy ce qui est
bien partout surtout dans les plis les
aisselles et coude mais
nous les organes génitaux le cif le
sillon auteurs fessier mais aussi dans
les trous 1 comme le nombril les
oreilles et et les hommes poilus genre
les cheveux n'hésitez pas à vous
examinez mutuellement si vous êtes
plusieurs à l'or plutôt avec des gens
avec qui vous êtes à l'aise un de
préférence et n'oubliez pas que ça peut
être vraiment tout petit donc n'hésitez
pas non plus à recommencer l'inspection
le lendemain
si big mac quand elles ont bien profité
quand elles ont bien mangé elles
grossissent pas mal donc des fois on les
voit mieux le lendemain astuce et si
vous avez un doute va aller demander à
votre formation
et tant que vous êtes à la pharmacie
profitez-en pour acheter un tire tique
c'est une sorte de petit pied de biche
en plastique qui a été spécialement
conçu pour retirer les squats jeu alors
il y en a des tout petits pour retirer
les toutes petites les nymphes et il y
en ad - petit pour retirer les mois un
petit pour bien faire il faut glisser
l'objet autour de la tique aura de la
peau à perpendiculaire et tiré sans vous
ruiner mais quand même un petit peu
fermement et en faisant un léger
mouvement de rotation
ça permet d'enlever la bestiole en
entier sans lui arracher la tête ou le
rostre et donc sans en laisser un
morceau plantés dans la peau
plus vite vous faites ça mieux c'est
parce que moins longtemps la tic restent
en place - elle a le temps de vous
refiler une saloperie si elle a une
saloperie parce que encore une fois
c'est pas obligé calmez vous et quand
même dans le doute
mettez de l'antiseptique sur la morsure
et surveiller la pendant un mois
si vous avez une rougeur qui s'étend en
cercle au niveau de la morsure ou même
ailleurs
si vous êtes très fatiguée si vous avez
de la fièvre des douleurs dans les
articulations si vous ressentez des
fourmillements voir des paralysies dans
le visage ou dans les membres évidemment
vous allez chez le médecin il vous
prescrira des antibiotiques si besoin
pour tuer la mort est due à la bactérie
et comme d'habitude vous pouvez signaler
la morsure aux autorités c'est pas pour
tout cas c'est pour qu'ils tiennent à
jour leur cartographie jeu
vous remets le lien dans la description
des lieux à est alors dernière chose
parce que je peux pas ne pas le
mentionner
vous avez peut-être entendu parler de
tout un tas de polémique autour de la
maladie de lyme son diagnostic son
traitement etc
bon ici là c'est pas le sujet mais je
vous mets des liens dans la description
de la vidéo si vous voulez vous
renseigner et éventuellement on peut en
reparler plus tard dans une autre vidéo
si ça vous intéresse donc n'hésitez pas
à me le dire
en attendant dtc c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos
profitez bien de l'été prenez soin de
vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]